and Anish giri well he's still in here
looking over this game will he be
annoyed with himself now somehow yeah I
would not do what Anish is doing right
now he's on chest 24 I really like that
this feature they have where you can see
the computer evaluation after each move
he's going to see that even in the final
position he had a big advantage and he's
going to see that actually most of the
whole game he had the advantages
blackened it was just bailing out which
was understandable at the end he didn't
have too much time on the clock but if
the match turns against him now he'll
pinpoint this one moment as his big
chance against the world champion and
there we can see even on his screen the
evaluation bar was all the way down on
Black's favor
um so yeah I wouldn't be checking on
this game I would just be looking ahead
to the next one he's got white after all
in the next game and uh he will have
chances just forget this one move on and
still one one yeah and here he is
leaving uh the arena Anish giri let's uh
see if it stops